whoa how's it going you found me I'm
Waldo surprise we've been making videos
for a long time now and I was thinking
you know what you'd really be cool to
try out a whole new format obviously 360
videos have become very popular over the
last year or two but a lot of people
have been having trouble wrapping their
heads around just one is to have a 360
video we decided to kick it off with one
super cool idea Where's Waldo in 360 so
as the perfect excuse to do a 360 video
because it actually encourages you to
look around you're trying to find Waldo
right we of course looked at all the 360
cameras that you can buy out there from
various different companies they're all
great however they all seem to kind of
pop out of like 1080p and we wanted to
be able to do like 4k right because you
need that extra resolution and really
hone in and see where Waldo is so we end
up deciding well we've got a bunch of
GoPros this 3d printer rig and do some
experiments so we did so the rig we
ended up coming up with is five GoPros
all pointed in different directions on a
3d printed rig so that gives us a huge
amount of resolution all around the
board
everybody knows Waldo when we were out
shooting every single person was
pointing at Rennes and saying I found
you what was even freakier for people
with seeing a whole group of Waldo
look-alikes walking around with him that
was very reassuring when we were filming
this video because the fact that you
know people are pointing us out knowing
what we're doing is perfect we went to
the Santa Monica Pier and the Santa
Monica area in general to film this on a
Sunday afternoon when people were just
packed there and Where's Waldo universe
you need to have a lot of people you
need to have objects for people to look
at while they're watching the 360 video
so it was very important that we had
enough people on each day that could
cause basically distractions
we had a Mario we had a guy in a pizza
costume when shooting with these 360
rigs and specifically ours we had no way
to actually look at the footage how
would we know how far away Waldo should
or shouldn't be how would we know if
he's even close enough to be seen in the
camera we ended up developing a funny
trick I call it the rule of finger we
put the camera down Ren would go to a
hiding spot I'd stand at the rig and
hold my finger up and if he was about
the size of my finger from the cameras
perspective then that way we knew you'd
be close enough to the camera to be seen
so one of the challenges we faced with
this video is you still to direct the
viewers
just a little bit there's two strategies
that we employed first off right below
the video is where the stand use we can
put instructions there like Where's
Waldo where's the magician where is the
wizard as they're scanning around
they're catching all these little things
everywhere you look there's something
cool going on not just anywhere ever
Waldo is hiding but after doing the
first test I realized that we need to
kind of give the viewers something to
follow and one of the takes Sam and I
were walking orbiting basically the
360-degree camera and so he kind of gave
a little bit of a tour through the shot
so an action would happen some event
would happen we'd run after another
character then eventually at the end of
the shot we see Waldo when we run after
Waldo so it's kind of like providing the
solution to the puzzle at the very end
so now they actually have the footage
from your different GoPros it's time to
stitch them together and so we looked at
a few different video stitching
software's out there and we ended up
settling with Auto panel Pro from the
company color they were bought out by
GoPro at some point so they actually
worked really nicely with GoPro footage
and the whole process is actually pretty
simple and straightforward use kind of
load your footage hit stitch so we had
all the GoPros hooked up to one of those
GoPro remotes however they don't all
record at exactly the same time and
that's where a lot of like the video
stitching errors kind of comes from is
if you have two GoPros slightly
oftentime so it causes like what looks
like a stitching error whereas in
reality the stitching is just fine it's
the time offset that's killing you so
what I found to be the best way to
synchronize the stuff is literally just
to pick up the entire rig and spin it
just like back and forth and the
software actually takes that motion
analyzes it and then times up all the
different clips together just by looking
at that motion of the cameras you first
synchronize all the footage then you
stitch all the footage and honestly Auto
pano video stitch they all do that
automatically very fast so how do you
put visual effects into a 360 video well
first you got to put it on to something
and generally what you're putting it
onto is something called an equi
rectangular Mack if the best example
this is imagine you have a globe of the
earth and then you have a map of the
earth and that map of the earth you're
looking at it's called an echo a
rectangular map basically it's taking
the sphere and unwrapping it out so what
skybox studio allows us to do is project
images onto these equirectangular maps
but also rida stored it so it fits
perfectly into that spherical image that
you're seeing on the screen it's
basically a way to make things
distorted properly
yeah so shooting this video was a really
cool experience
it's always fun messing around with new
camera technologies and kind of
experimenting with you know the ways
people can view content I'd love to hear
how it works for you guys if you manage
to find Waldo he thought I was
interesting he had any technical issues
there we're hoping to do a lot more 360
content in the future just because the
fun new format we're gonna continue
trying to make cool 360 videos the rest
of the year know there's what no no you
just richt me this is I I hate you
because this is so smart there's a Mario
and a toad just randomly in there - oh
you're getting married there's so much
happy it's a very interesting thing is
when you do make something where the
video is everything around you you have
to figure out how to fill the hole